Trascrizione: Beatrice Romano'
Revisore: Federico MINELLE
(Applausi)
Quello che vi racconto oggi
è una storia d'amore,
e come tutte le storie d'amore
che si rispettino
ha un inizio un po' complicato.
Quando mi sono iscritto
alla facoltà di Ingegneria
del Politecnico di Milano nel 2008
quando ti iscrivi, all'università dici:
Io cambierò il mondo!
Distruggo tutto, no!
Distruggo, rifaccio, spacco..
Però il problema nel 2008 era che
c'è stata questa famosa crisi, no?
E giornale dopo giornale.. mai una crisi
così nera.. la peggiore crisi dal ‘45,
tu pensi che sia solo in Italia,
o che comunque che magari
i giornali italiani esagerano e poi:
o no, anche il Wall Street Journal!
Allora sarà una cosa vera, è reale!
E quello che le persone fanno quando
c'è un periodo, diciamo di disillusione
o comunque quando si vuole
staccare dalla realtà
si chiude gli occhi e si cerca appunto
qualcosa
che ci faccia pensare in un'altra maniera
e nel 2008 la cosa migliore
per distaccarti dalla realtà
era l'iPhone
perché era il momento in cui l'iPhone
stava entrando nel mercato.
L'iPhone era un nuovo mondo
perché per la prima volta avevo in tasca
tutte le mappe di cui avevo bisogno
tutte le mappe di cui non avevo bisogno
e potevo anche postare su Facebook
in qualsiasi momento e in qualsiasi posto
in cui mi trovassi
e quindi, cosa è successo?
All'epoca le app erano completamente
da come sono oggi
per esempio c'era iBook. E iBook aveva
questa grafica che aveva questi scaffali
con le venature del legno,
i colori del legno
Potevi sfogliare le pagine del libro,
era qualcosa di magico, era qualcosa
di davvero speciale all'epoca
Allora io, in quel momento ho capito che
volevo essere partecipe di questa magia
volevo essere un designer,
mi ero innamorato del design
però tra il dire e il fare, no,
c'è di mezzo il mare
nel mio caso c'era l'Olanda,
perché sono andato in Olanda
non era facile adattarsi in quel mondo
è andato più o meno cosi
ho dovuto organizzarmi e non è stato
abbastanza facile
però fortunatamente
sono arrivato in questa start-up
che si chiamava hubskip
e ho iniziato la carriera
come UX designer
allora la prima cosa che ho fatto
ho chiamato mio padre e mia madre
e ho detto: "mamma, papà,
sono un UX designer!"
e dopo cinque secondi di silenzio:
"un che?"
allora ho pensato: "ma forse il problema
non è solo di mia madre e di mio padre"
perché secondo Business Insider,
l'UX interface designer
è il lavoro più complicato da spiegare
ai propri genitori, in tutto il mondo.
E non è solo un lavoro complicato
da spiegare ai genitori,
è un lavoro complicato da spiegare.
Quindi ho pensato:
"ma come è possibile?"
Perché il design
è qualcosa di cosi naturale
qualcosa dentro di noi alla base
della nostra evoluzione come esseri umani
e nel mio caso specifico, io lavoro
con interfacce digitali.
L'interfaccia non è altro che un insieme
di finestre, bottoni e testo
che ti permette
di realizzare un certo scopo
nel caso di Facebook, per esempio,
è postare sul tuo wall, oppure vedere
quello che i tuoi amici stanno dicendo
in giro intorno al mondo.
Quindi le interfacce
non sono altro che strumenti
che noi utilizziamo per plasmare
e modificare il mondo che ci circonda,
quindi in una certa estensione
il martello è stata la prima forma
di interfaccia, perché ci ha permesso
di interagire e modificare
tutto quello che ci circondava
ma allora se è cosi naturale,
come mai il design e il designer
è cosi complicato da spiegare?
Beh, io personalmente penso
che il problema deriva
dal dualismo tra arte e design.
Allora, l'arte per molto tempo è stata
patrimonio di una cerchia ristretta di persone
basti pensare nel Rinascimento, quando
la Chiesa, praticamente, era padrona
non solo dell'arte e degli artisti,
ma anche della vita stessa degli artisti.
Quindi l'arte è stata,
anche nei tempi moderni,
era comunque patrimonio di una cerchia
ristretta di intellettuali e aristocratici
Bisognerà aspettare il 1920 con Walter
Grovius, che è stato il fondatore
della Bahaus, per dare un'idea di cosa
sia il design e cosa sia il designer.
Ora, secondo Grovius, bisognava creare
un nuovo metodo di insegnamento
che potesse creare un nuovo
tipo d'artista,
e questo tipo di artista era qualcuno
che era in grado di riconoscere
i problemi umani,
riconoscere i problemi umani,
non perché fosse un genio o un prodigio,
ma riconosceva i problemi umani
ed era capace di rispondere
a questi problemi
secondo un metodo preciso.
Per la prima volta abbiamo
una definizione di cos'è il design.
Adesso tu mi dirai: ma allora come si fa
a realizzare questo?
In un certo senso questo vuol dire,
per la prima volta l'arte
passava dall'essere qualcosa di formale,
all'essere qualcosa di utilitaristico,
quindi l'arte diventava
patrimonio della gente:
bisognava creare per la gente,
la gente al centro,
l'internet of the people.
Ma per fare questo,
bisogna spostare l'oggetto
della nostra osservazione
dal "come" al "perchè".
Perché il "come" eleva le nostre capacità
tecniche, le nostre capacità artistiche
perché ci permette di capire
quale tecnica vogliamo realizzare.
Però con il "perché" riusciamo
ad arrivare allo scopo delle cose,
riusciamo ad avere uno scopo delle cose
e riusciamo ad avere un punto di vista.
Ora, prima di lavorare per Facebook,
lavoravo ad Open Table.
Open Table è un'azienda in America
che si occupa di restaurant reservation,
quindi puoi prenotare un ristorante
in qualsiasi parte del mondo,
in qualsiasi orario.
E uno dei prodotti che Open Table offre
è il "Guest Center".
"Guest Center" è questa applicazione,
sia per mobile che web,
che permette ai ristoratori di vedere
quante persone stanno entrando
nel ristorante
se hanno particolari richieste,
possono essere allergie,
magari vogliono un tavolo particolare
e permette di vedere dove
queste persone saranno sedute,
basato su un algoritmo
che noi abbiamo creato.
Ora, quando abbiamo realizzato
questo prodotto
era importante capire per chi
stavamo realizzando questo prodotto.
Quindi siamo andati nei ristoranti
e abbiamo visto che i maggiori
utilizzatori di questo prodotto
erano camerieri e manager di ristoranti.
E molte volte i ristoranti
sono ambienti bui
perché bisogna creare l'atmosfera,
romantica e tutto il resto, giusto?
Quindi, quello che abbiamo fatto noi
quando creavamo il design,
vedevamo come quest'app
si comportava al buio,
proprio per capire, per creare quel design
che ci permetteva di avere un design
che non affaticasse gli occhi, o comunque
un design che fosse piacevole da usare
anche in ambienti poco illuminati
e quindi qui ci sta il mio amico Tom
che stava provando un po' quel design
quindi è molto importante.. la prima cosa
per creare prodotti che siano di successo
e prodotti che la gente apprezza,
è l'empatia,
perché noi ci siamo resi empatici
dei problemi di questi camerieri
e abbiamo cercato di risolverli
nel miglior modo possibile.
E uno dei motivi principali per cui
abbiamo creato questo tool
era perché tutti i tools che i ristoratori
usavano all'epoca, due anni fa,
erano tutti di questo tipo…
ed è bruttissimo, giusto?
Ѐ bruttissimo e anche difficile da usare.
Quindi, così come il "perché"
è fondamentale,
però bisogna anche non tralasciare
il "come" delle cose,
perché con il come arriviamo alla bellezza
e la bellezza è fondamentale perché
è stato dimostrato che le cose belle
creano una risposta positiva nel cervello
che aumenta le nostre capacità cognitive
e ci permette di risolvere
i nostri problemi più in fretta.
Quindi le cose belle
stimolano la creatività
e quindi, giusto per farvi rivedere
un attimo la comparazione
... questo è stato dopo
... questo è stato prima
e quando la gente usava questo prodotto,
ci volevano anni,
c'era gente che aveva tre, quattro anni
di esperienza solo per capire
come far funzionare questo.
Quando noi abbiamo fatto questo:
dieci minuti
e la gente sapeva come
usare questa applicazione,
e faceva esattamente le stesse cose
che faceva quella vecchia applicazione.
Ora, una delle cose belle della bellezza,
è che noi come esseri umani
siamo portati a ricordare
molto più facilmente le esperienze belle
di quelle negative.
Inoltre, è stato anche dimostrato che se
abbiamo una buona esperienza su un sito,
una persona molto probabilmente
tornerà su quel sito
per avere lo stesso tipo di esperienza.
Questa è stata una delle basi che abbiamo
utilizzato quando abbiamo lavorato
al redesign di Open Table.
In questo caso potete vedere come,
appena aperto il sito,
abbiamo l'immagine di questa gente
che sta cenando o pranzando insieme
e questo crea quella risposta emotiva
di dire..
cioè la persona che vede
questo sito pensa,
sta quasi pregustando quel momento
quando avrà quella cena
o quel pranzo con i propri amici.
E un'altra delle cose molto interessanti
di questa immagine
è che è stato dimostrato che
i volti sono speciali, cioè
c'è una parte speciale del nostro cervello
che è fatta per riconoscere i volti.
Non solo per riconoscere i volti,
ma ha anche una risposta
molto positiva ai volti.
E questo è stato un altro dei principi
che abbiamo usato
quando abbiamo quest'altra feature
che praticamente ti fa vedere
nei vari ristoranti quali dei tuoi amici
ha già prenotato questo ristorante.
E questo è stato dimostrato che ha avuto
un impatto molto positivo,
perchè in questo modo le persone
erano capaci di vedere
quali amici avevano riservato
il ristorante
e ha permesso di focalizzarsi molto di più
sul prenotare questo ristorante
anzichè un altro.
E questo è come il sito di Open Table
era prima del redesign.
E quindi una volta che abbiamo applicato
tutti questi concetti,
abbiamo avuto il 40% in più
di utilizzo del nostro sito,
in più la Apple ci ha nominato
in vari Award.
E quindi è stato un design che è stato
davvero molto positivo.
E adesso voi direte:
"vabbè ma è facile per te riconoscere
cosa è bello e cosa è no
perchè lo fai per lavoro.
Però io vi voglio sorprendere
un pochettino.
La bellezza è dentro ognuno di noi:
ci sono degli ideali,
ci sono delle proporzioni
che sono universali, che accendono
quell'area del cervello
e ci fanno sentire bene.
E queste proporzioni sono
le stesse proporzioni
che sono state utilizzate nel Partenone,
che sono state utilizzate
nei quadri di Leonardo,
nella Cappella Sistina,
e quindi quello che ho fatto oggi per voi,
ho creato il design
di questo blog fittizio
e ne ho fatto due versioni,
una versione utilizza
quelle che sono le proporzioni,
le geometrie, le armonie umane
e l'altra no.
E io voglio per alzata di mano
che mi dite secondo voi
non quale utilizzi quale,
ma quale voi preferite. Ok?
Allora questa è la prima versione
E questa é la seconda.
Faccio di nuovo
prima
seconda
Per alzata di mano,
quanti preferiscono la prima?
Quanti la seconda?
La prima è quella che rispetta
le proporzioni del corpo umano
e che il nostro cervello
riconosce come "perfette".
Quindi la bellezza è dentro ognuno di noi.
(applausi)
E adesso come possiamo
utilizzare questi principi
per creare il design del futuro?
Beh il futuro io spero che non sia
qualcosa di così
perchè, se vivi in California
questo è il futuro,
Ci sta il selfie stick,
ci sta l'overboard, ci sta...
spero che il futuro non sia questo.
Però nel futuro,
la migliore interfaccia
sarà l'assenza di interfaccia,
quindi ci saranno una serie
di prodotti e servizi
che ci permetteranno
di fare delle scelte senza scegliere.
Quello è il futuro del design.
Quindi è proprio il limite
dell'empatia, della bellezza,
perchè non c'è più scelta.
E vi faccio un esempio
Io oggi, il 7 Maggio sarei dovuto essere
a questa conferenza,
immaginiamo che creo un evento
sul mio calendario
7 Maggio devo essere a Torino
senza che io faccia nulla,
c'è questo servizio che:
mi prenota il volo, mi prenota l'hotel,
e tutto è prenotato in base
alle mie esperienze personali
quale compagnia aerea preferisco,
che tipo di cibo preferisco,
se voglio viaggiare in business
o voglio viaggiare in first class
perchè ci saranno questi servizi
che avranno acquisito
talmente tanti dati su di noi
che ci permetteranno
di fare delle azioni
che adesso sono tediose,
nella maniera
più semplice possibile.
Quindi il compito del designer
sarà non più di creare
prodotti digitali o reali,
ma sarà di confezionare queste esperienze
che devono essere
il più semplice possibile.
Quindi il designer non farà altro
che spezzettare tutti
questi vari passaggi
e rendere la vita delle persone
più facile.
In conclusione,
per cambiare il mondo attorno a noi
bisogna davvero capire
quali sono le esigenze delle persone
cioè farsi responsabili,
essere empatici,
capire cosa le persone vogliono.
Henry Ford, che è il fondatore
di Ford Motors
è famoso per aver detto
quando lui chiedeva alla gente
che cosa voleva
la gente diceva:
"voglio un cavallo più veloce"
e questo perchè
la gente si chiedeva,
come fa un cavallo ad essere più veloce?
Come, come, come.
Invece Henry ha detto:
"perchè un cavallo?
Io ti faccio l'automobile."
Quindi è davvero importante
focalizzarsi sul perchè delle cose,
capire quali sono i problemi della gente.
C'è Benigni che ha detto tante cose,
però in una delle sue frasi
da me preferite, lui dice:
"la bellezza è iniziata quando
noi abbiamo iniziato a scegliere."
Quindi io quello che
vi voglio dire oggi è:
scegliete quello che volete fare,
fatelo nel modo più bello possibile
perchè l'internet of the people
non è altro che questo:
è bellezza ed empatia ad ogni click.
Grazie
(Applausi)